und leute nochmal macht es auch keins
nachbezahlt für die sachen ich würde
auch nichts umsonst rausnehmen wenn es
um den sensor auszutricksen müsst ihr
einen anderen gegenstand rennen legen um
den fall des produktes abzufedern
ich versuche jetzt mal mit dem pulli dem
gewicht sind sogar schon auszuschalten
okay leute ich bin fertig wären es hier
aus dieser mine szene praktisch zwei
zehner gemacht das gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut
heute gibt's kriminellen immer neuen
video also was heißt sein
ihr solltet das auf jeden fall besser
nicht ausprobieren ich bin sehr
skeptisch demgegenüber ob das wirklich
klappt auf jeden fall kurze
vorgeschichte wir haben den letzten tick
tock fix gemacht
umsonst getränke aus dem automaten zu
befördern das hat nicht geklappt kann
hier viel offen und ehrlich sagen viele
von euch haben es wahrscheinlich auch
schon gesehen da habe ich ganz viele
videos bekommen wo mir leute
irgendwelche automaten hacks geschickt
haben
ich habe mir die angeguckt und habe
jetzt mal vier ausgesucht womit man sich
so einen automaten überlisten könnte wir
haben jetzt auch schon ein bisschen
später das heißt wir sind hoffentlich am
automaten dann ungestört und trotzdem
ist das natürlich alles klappen sollte
schneide ich das wahrscheinlich raus
also ihr werdet und merken dass es
klappt aber ich schmeiße raus weil es
werden dann würde ich euch zeigen wie
man also dann würde ich eine straftat
film auch wenn es nur ein euro für
schokoriegel ist und so ich bin euch
gleich immer die hacks 1 1 müssen wir
noch kurz präpariert und zwar nennt er
sich die gefälschte banknote juli hat
mich freundlicherweise einen zehner
gegeben denn niemand mehr annehmen
wollten wir mal kurz zu ende durch
composite weg 18 euro hier war werbung
rein läuft wieder hier ist jetzt meine
aufgabe die sind zehn so zu präparieren
wie hier im video erklärt wurde
viel spaß die gefälschte banknote da ist
wohl jemand kurz davor etwas geld zu
verlieren nehmt euch irgend einen
geldschein und schneidet ihn in zwei
hälften jetzt nehmt ihr euch ein
bisschen zeitungspapier oder etwas
ähnliches man schneidet ein stück papier
in derselben größe mit dem echten schein
aus der nächste schritt ist die echte
hälfte und das volk im schnitt mit
klebeband zu verbinden schon seid ihr
bereit für betrügerische machenschaften
gibt entscheiden mit der rechten hälfte
nach vorne in den automaten
die maschine wird das wasserzeichen der
echten hälfte des scheins lesen und
nicht den falschen teil prüfen
auf diese weise könnt ihr den wert des
scheins verdoppeln
okay leute ich bin fertig wären wir es
hier aus diesem einen zehner praktisch
zwei zehner gemacht ja die haben zu dem
video erklärt dass hier wird irgendwie
nur vorne diese hat dieses zeug gelesen
und dann soll der wohl schon akzeptiert
werden wobei ich das nicht glaube wegen
jetzt erstmals autofahren zu einem
automaten und was ich noch unbedingt
sagen wollte falls irgendwas davon knapp
ich werde das natürlich nicht zuende
ausführen also ich werde da nicht klauen
also ich werde die aktion abbrechen okay
leute wir sind jetzt hier in so einem
kleinen bahnhof hier gibt es einen
automaten
ich hoffe da ist fast niemand ich habe
übrigens auch noch ihren laserpointer
herausgekramt den brauchen wir ja auch
noch um den sensor vom automaten
auszuschalten und leute nochmal macht es
auch keins nachbezahlt für die sachen
ich würde auch nichts umsonst rausnehmen
wenn die automaten sind zum großen teil
sicherlich auch videoüberwacht und daher
manchmal schon mal bei uns die erste
anzeige sei ein flotter wenn paar
sekunden später
es geht aber auch immer irgendwie schief
erstens vor diesem automaten saß eine
ganze gruppe voller sonne ließ zweitens
der automat konnte keine scheine nehmen
ich frage mich sowieso gibt es
süßigkeiten automaten in deutschland die
scheine nehmen ich hatte nämlich schon
sehr auf das wurde bestimmt am flughafen
also keine ahnung wir fahren jetzt auf
jeden fall noch woanders hin
sonst hätte ich das bei einem
zigarettenautomat müsste ja eigentlich
dürfte nicht ganz anders sein okay fängt
ja schon richtig gut an weiteren okay
leute werden jetzt ein automaten
gefunden
das ist kuriert weil hier sind so ein
paar menschen die hören uns halt so ist
ein bisschen blöd
na ja ich versuche jetzt einfach mal
ganz normal und ansonsten ich wünsche
euch viel spaß ein geheimcode
wahrscheinlich wisst ihr dass jeder
automat ein geheimcode hat um seinen
zustand zu prüfen
nur der besitzer der maschine und der
handwerker kennen den code trotzdem ist
es ziemlich einfach
ihr müsst einfach nur drei knöpfe im
auswahlmenü drücken diejenigen die
automaten bestehen wollen wollen jetzt
bestimmt wissen welche drei knöpfe oder
die kombination ist bei jedem automaten
anders so dass ihr euch schon ein
bisschen mühe geben müsst die meisten
leute sagen aber dass die drei köpfe
normalerweise ein leben einander sind
okay
121 ohne führung zu erklären habe ich
hier einfach mal alle codes ausprobiert
die irgendwie in der reihe war aber
keine ahnung alles was mir so einen kopf
bekommen es bestimmt 50 stück aber 999 4
5 6 7 8 9 10
ja ich versuche konnten sollte das geht
ich sitze schon im schnitt also das war
der erste da hab ich irgendwie nicht so
viel zugesagt ist mir jetzt gerade im
schnitt aufgefallen deswegen ich habe
wirklich eine menge kurz probiert ja
auch schon in diesem sektor live video
kann sein dass gibt bestimmten code aber
darauf zu kommen also ich schätze das
als unmöglich sein kann man ja gut mit
einer bankkarte vergleich nicht mein tag
kann man ja auch nicht einfach so irgend
eine bankkarte hecken weil man mit zwei
versuchen den code knackt also das würde
ich mal als sehr fragwürdig einstufen
hat bei uns auf jeden fall nicht
funktioniert und wir haben wirklich sehr
sehr viele verschiedene varianten
getestet
okay leute jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
jetzt machen wir denn mit dem
laserpointer und mit dem gewichts
abfangen praktisch man sieht auf jeden
fall da ich weiß nicht ob man das ding
kann auch viele kammern und sensor und
da aber es sind halt zwei
ich war so die bewegungs und gewicht
sensoren mit diesen tricks sieht es
wirklich so aus als würde dir etwas
kaufen alles was ihr tun müsst ist euch
für ein produkt zu entscheiden und die
richtige geldsumme in den schlitz
einzuwerfen die maschine wird das geld
automatisch zählen wählt danach mit dem
buchstaben unterzahl das produkt auch
das wir haben wollten
danach lädt die metall schraube anfangen
das produkt freizugeben die sache ist
aber dass automaten bewegungs und
gewicht sensoren haben die da maschine
sagen lasst das produkt ausgegeben wurde
um die bewegungssensoren auszutricksen
braucht ihr einfach nur ein laserpointer
oder ähnliches normalerweise befindet
sich der bewegungssensor am boden der
maschine und es ziemlich einfach zu
finden der gewicht sensor ist im unteren
fach wenn das das produkt fällt um den
sensor auszutricksen müsst ihr einen
anderen gegenstand reinlegen um den fall
des produktes abzufedern ein schales
dabei perfekt geeignet diese methode
funktioniert nur bei leichten objekten
wie schokoriegeln oder chips habt ihr
alles richtig gemacht dann wird euch der
automat alle produkte in derselben reihe
wie das ausgewählte produkt ausgeben
wenn man mal den automaten der switch
aber dass er jetzt genau der gleiche
ich versuche jetzt mal mit dem pulli den
gewicht sensor schon auszuschalten
jetzt weiß auch es könnte klappen
es war ich mein geld ich nehme jetzt die
42 dass das coelho dafür brauche ich
eine und jetzt im magic beginnt 42 jetzt
kann man hier fällt jetzt da er wurde
nicht abgeführt hat noch etwas leichter
aber gemacht als man jetzt den laser
ausschalten können
ja also das klappt ja und da ist es
abgefedert worden
also eigentlich alles klappt müssen die
habe um das gelände und jetzt bin ich
hier die 43
hey mann
das hat geklappt ich weiß nicht ob wir
zu neuester für oder ob sie generell
wahrscheinlich geht es generell ist aber
nochmal wenn man sollte es nicht nur
noch mein mann sollte ist nicht neu aber
hast du lust auf
nein wollte sich keiner gesagt wenn die
jugend
die haben ja nichts zu tun um die
uhrzeit also das erste ist absolut
gefällt das ist dann auch geflogen und
danach unter geknallt das zweite ist
schön perfekt gelandet hat es schon
klappen können aber ich habe den sensor
nicht geblendet
beim dritten habe ich den sensor
geblendet und das ist perfekt gelandet
aber es hat absolut nichts geholfen
meine idee habe ich noch und zwar bleibe
ich euch hier bei den nächsten ein
dieser trick funktioniert natürlich
nicht bei jedem automat aber bei manchen
neueren automaten ist es immer noch
möglich wenn dieser automat befördert
das gewünschte getränk mit einem
förderband zur ausgabe so geht's geld
einwerfen getränk wählen und mit der
hand die getränkeausgabe blockieren
beziehungsweise gegen die klappe drücken
nach kurzer zeit wirft der automat
wieder das geld heraus und du kannst es
erneut ein werfen da auf dem förderband
noch das getränk vom mai zuvor ist wirst
du beim nächsten mal wenn du nicht die
ausgabe lakies zwei getränke bekommen im
preis von einem
da ging es ja daran dass das getränk
praktisch nicht entgegengenommen hier
wenn ich das hier zu halten
wird das ja da unten nicht erkannt dann
würde jeder dann machen ja also leute
wir haben das dann bei so einem
getränkeautomat versucht wo man die hand
wirklich reinstecken konnte und man
konnte auch das getränk blockieren wie
ihr vielleicht so sehen könnt ich habe
das gepixelt aber das geld das nicht
wieder rausgekommen
also es hat auch nicht funktioniert im
alter was ist denn da los
wie schnell und wie so was halt in köln
ganz normal also es ist echt grausam was
für gestaltendes uhrzeit rumrennen die
einschlagen sich aus den einführung
gesehen da hat mich die ganze zeit so
anguckt also wirklich gruselig jetzt
sehr gut ich kann spart so ich habe die
ganze zeit ein paar ausgeschlossen wird
weil ich nur positiv gestalten jetzt um
die uhrzeiten würden also das einzige
was jetzt noch fehlen würde wäre das mit
dem geldschein aber diese ganzen
automaten hier hatten neben halt keine
geldscheine sondern nur münzen hätte ich
auch vor drauf kommen können aber in dem
video gut das war ein amerikanischer
automatisch waren dollarscheine deswegen
wir brauchen einen zigarettenautomat
problem ist in köln gibt es fast keine
zigaretten auch nicht nur einer ist in
beiden recht da weiß ich meine safe zu
100 100 können wir dann auch in frage
ja das steht aus liegt es vielleicht
daran weil du bist nicht mehr nicht mehr
ich habe aufgehört da jetzt noch hin und
dann okay leute hinter uns ist jetzt nur
ein zigarettenautomat den wir
glücklicherweise gefunden haben ich
mache jetzt das mit dem schein tendiert
das wahrscheinlich oder so weil ich wäre
hier auf nummer sicher gehen auch wenn
ich niemals irgendwas wenn es klappen
sollte wenn ich niemals irgendwas
umsonst mir da ziehen würde also das
wäre total dumm das auch noch zu filmen
wir probieren halt nur theoretisch
klappt was ich aber auch nicht glaube
dass wir so dumm alter okay wir
versuchen es einmal
ich meine ich teste das ja auch für euch
aus damit ihr nicht irgendwie glaubt
dass das funktioniert ja ganz wichtig
dann mal los
antwort warte ich gebe nicht auf noch
mal das kann ja manchmal passieren also
ist funktioniert auf jeden fall schon
mal halt nein warte dann es kann sein
dass wir die falsche seite für das thema
diesem jahr von euch haben jetzt zwei
ich finde es gut dass hier passiert gar
nichts sehen wie die leute wir sind
wieder zurück also ich habe jetzt mal
einen cut gesetzt das hat auch nicht
funktioniert
aber es war trotzdem relativ interessant
das ein oder andere mal aus zu dessen
ich hoffe dass wir auch für euch
unterhaltsamen kommt natürlich vor schon
denken das ist meist nicht funktioniert
aber ganz sicher war ich mir auch nicht
sein das wurde ja schon ziemlich
überzeugend erklärt in diesem video aber
vielleicht geht es auch nur bei
amerikanischen automaten hätten die
falschen keine ahnung haben aber noch
den zigarettenautomat getestet jetzt
auch nicht angenommen
ich habe das ja auch alles zensiert
besser trotzdem hoffe ich dass es euch
gefallen lassen doch nach oben da und
wir sehen uns dann übermorgen wieder
gibt's neues video und sorry das ist
halt gar nichts geklappt hat aber das
kann ich auch nichts für sie